President Swigert trustees distinguished
guests my fellow honorees my Shero dr.
Dorothy Height graduates parents friends
what a deep honor to be here today for
me I think dr. gates said it best you
can receive a lot of awards in your life
but there is nothing better
there is nothing better than to be
honored by your own thank you thank you
I'll be calling myself dr. Winfrey on
Monday morning on The Oprah Show well
let me just say that everybody I know
who's ever graduated from here and
that's a lot of y'all told me just wait
till you get there just wait till you
get there they said to me you're gonna
feel the love and Howard I am feeling
you today I'm feeling you today I thank
you for the honor of being able to
celebrate with you today I'm here
because my good friend and former
executive producer of the oprah winfrey
show Diane Hudson a new member of the
Howard Board of Trustees said to me
you've got to come to Howard Howard is
the bomb Diane Hudson said it is our
pride is it is a mighty force you just
have to experience a girl and she told
me that she said once you come it's
going to feel like family reunion and
you're going to want to come again and
again Thank You Diane because it's your
passion and your commitment to
excellence and created continued
excellence for this great institution
that made me stop whatever I was
planning on doing and get to Howard and
I'm really so glad I did because I get
to see you all I get to witness and
welcome you all to the beginning of your
new and fantastic life ahead if you
choose it to be so and I know that it is
therefore the choosing because there is
nobody more nurtured and prepared to
lead us into an exemplary future than
the howard university graduating class
of two thousand seven
I i can say that nobody knows for sure
where you go in your life what impact
you will have on others but each of one
of us may have a better chance than most
because you all have spent four years
responding to the nurturing which is the
truest meaning of teaching you sat in
your different classes you you've tested
you've done your reports you've turned
in your exams and you deserve to be here
today congratulations and after all the
partying is over and I know there will
be some partying up in here the anxiety
may start to creep in what do you now do
with all of this education I'm here to
tell you today don't worry don't worry
about it relax take a breath you're in
really good hands because God's got your
back all you need to do is know who you
are and I know you know who you are
because I have as a part of my harpo
production team two former graduates of
Howard 1991 294 Terry Mitchell and
Jackie Taylor who came with me today and
all the way here they were telling me
that when you leave Howard one thing you
know for sure is who you are because
Howard teaches you to define yourself by
your own terms and not by somebody
else's definition so here are a few
things I want you to know that I know
for sure don't be afraid all you have to
know is who you are because there is no
such thing as failure there is no such
thing as failure what other people label
or might try to call
failure I have learned is just God's Way
appointing you in a new direction so
it's true you may take several paths
that end up on what might be a dead end
for you at the moment but this is what I
also know for sure you must trust in the
words of my favorite bible verse that
say and know that the the Lord will lead
you to a rock that is higher than thou
every one of us has a calling there is a
reason why you are here I know this for
sure and that reason is greater than any
degree it's greater than any paycheck
and it's greater than anything anybody
can tell you that you're supposed to do
your real job is to find out what the
reason is and get about the business of
doing it you're calling isn't something
that somebody can tell you about it's
what you feel it is a part of your life
force it is the thing that gives you
juice the thing that you're supposed to
do and nobody can tell you what that is
you know it inside yourself you know I
come from good stock dr. schweigert was
mentioning my grandmother who had a
dream for me and her dream was not a big
dreamer dream was that one day I could
grow up she used to say I want you to
grow up and get yourself some good white
folks because my grandmother was a maid
and she worked for white folks her whole
life and her idea of having a big dream
was to was to have white folks who at
least treated her with some dignity who
showed her a little bit respect and she
used to say I want you to I hope you get
some good white folks that are kind to
you and I regret that she didn't live
past 1963 to see that I did grow up and
get some really good white folks working
for me
oh yeah
so have no fear have no fear God's got
your back and sometimes sometimes you
find out what you're supposed to be
doing by doing the things you're not
supposed to do so don't expect the
perfect job that defines your life's
work to come along next week if that
happens take the blessing and run with
it but if not be grateful to be on the
path where you eventually want to live
abide in the space of gratitude because
this is what I know for sure that only
through being grateful for how far you
come in your path can you leave room for
more blessings to flow blessings flow in
the space of gratitude everything in
your life is happening to teach you more
about yourself so even in a crisis be
grateful when disappointed be grateful
when things aren't going the way you
want them to be grateful that you have
sense enough to turn it around I spent
eight years in Baltimore I knew in those
years in Baltimore that I was unhappy
being a television news reporter but the
voice of my father who thought he knew
what I was supposed to do was in my head
he'd say don't you give up that job girl
you never gonna make $25,000 in one year
that's my father's dream for me but God
could dream a bigger dream than you can
dream for yourself and so I tried to
live in the space of God's dream and the
television executives told me when I was
in Baltimore that I was just it was too
much I was too big and I was too black
they told me that I was to engage that I
was too emotional I was too too much for
the news and so they put me on a talk
show one day just to run out my contract
and that was the beginning of my story
so I say even when things are difficult
be grateful honor your calling don't
worry about how successful you will be
don't worry about it focus on how
significant you can be in service and
the success will take care of itself and
always take a stand for yourself your
values your defined by what you stand
for your integrity is not for sale from
the very beginning of my career in
Baltimore and I walked in the room and
all the men in the room said to me you
need to change your name because
nobody's going to remember your name you
need to change your name and I said what
do you want me to change they said we
think Susie is a good name Susie is a
friendly named Susie is a name that
people will remember people can relate
to Susie I said I think I'm going to
keep my name if we will remember it or
not it is my name you have to be willing
to stand up for what you believe in if I
if I could count the number of times I
have been asked to compromise and sell
out myself for one reason or another I
would be a billionaire ten times over my
integrity is not for sale and neither is
yours
there are many times there were many
times died in hudson who was working
with me for 20 years can tell you this
many times when we were told that we
would lose the advertisers we would lose
the ratings i said i'm going to take the
high road they said you won't be able to
survive in this business taking the high
road you won't be able to get the
numbers the advertisers will drop out
and I said let them let them we will
chart our own course we will stand up
for what we believe in and 21 years
later we're still the number one show
the human death of our integrity is the
most we have to offer and I would
beseech you to remember what Harriet
Tubman said of her efforts to spirit
slaves from the plantation Harriet
Tubman once said that she could have
liberated thousands more if only she
could have convinced them that they were
slaves so do not be a slave to any form
of selling out maintain your integrity
it has always been I believe the only
solution to all of the problems in the
world and it remains the only solution
through your presence here today you
come from a long line of giants whose
shoulders you stand on giants who
graduated from this school and Giants
who never made it to school I believe in
the words of Jimmy Baldwin your crown
has been paid for so put it on your head
and wear it your crown has been paid for
and so as you walk forth from this place
these hallowed grounds today the most
important lesson i can offer you from my
own life is that in order to remain
successful to continue to wear the crown
as you walk the path the privilege you
must not forget the less privileged
you've left behind you cannot continue
to succeed in the world or have a
fulfilling life in the world unless you
choose to use your life in service
somehow to others and give back what you
have been given that's how you keep it
that's how you get it that's how you
grow it we are in a crisis in this
country with black youth they don't know
what you know they're falling and
they're failing they're dropping out at
the rates of fifty percent and higher
because we our generation didn't teach
them who they are we have a
responsibility to raise them up to lift
them up to save them to liberate them
from themselves go out and save a child
and sometimes it doesn't even take a lot
to save somebody as you all know I built
this beautiful school in South Africa
and I spend a lot of time trying to grow
my daughter's into a future as bright as
yours and I can't wait to see some of
them come to Howard University recently
I was with them and we were all sitting
around talking about careers and the
possibility for them and I speak to what
is possible when you see me you see what
is possible many years ago I saw Sidney
Poitier received the Academy Award in
1964 I was 10 years old and I watched
him get the Academy Award for lilies of
the field and as he accepted his award
I'd never seen a black man on television
in a suit I've never seen a black man
get out of a limousine and go anywhere
on television and when I saw Cindy
Fortier accept his Academy Award for
lilies of the field I remember sitting
on my and linoleum floor babysitting for
my half sister and brother saying if a
black man can do that I wonder what I
can do I stand here a symbol of what is
possible when you believe in the dream
of your own life I stand as a symbol of
that turtle on the fence somebody helped
me to get here just as I know you were
helped to get here Howard because I know
a lot of you came here with only the
clothes on your back and a dream for
what could be
and so as you have been saved as you
have been liberated you must liberate
others I want to share this story about
one of our honorees here today I was in
class with all of my girls and we were
talking about careers and a lot of my
girls say they want to be doctors
because they have seen the ravages of
aid and they want to grow up and be
doctors and some say they want to teach
and others say they want to to sing or
act or dance and there was one girl one
girl who said she wanted to be a
historian and all the other girls
started to snicker because I don't think
they'd heard the word historian and
later that afternoon I saw her sitting
in the computer lab and she was slumped
in the chair and I said then Delhi tell
me why are you sitting slumped in the
chair and she said I'm feeling very
silly I'm feeling very very very sad I
said why she said because I'm not like
the other girls they all want to be
really fun things but i have to tell you
mom oprah history is my passion when i
read about the ancestors it makes me
come alive so we're sitting there at the
computer and I said you know what I know
a famous historian let's see if we can
look him up on the computer and so we
punched in dr. Henry Louis Gates and her
expression her expression was you mean
he's black and she said Nez alive I said
yeah he's both black and alive I said
you know what I'm going to email him and
see if he'll email us back so I email
dr. Henry Louis Gates and I told him
about my my daughter who was feeling
ostracized because she wasn't like all
the other girls who wanted to be fun
things and dr. gates emailed back a
three-page letter telling her how as a
young boy he too was one of the only
ones who wanted to be a scholar a Rhodes
Scholar telling her how
oh they carry the torch of our ancestors
into the future telling her how it's all
right to be what you want to be and as
she read that letter I had her read the
letter out loud before me I saw her
shoulders get a little straighter I saw
her head get a little taller I saw her
straighten her back and I saw the
biggest smile I've ever seen come from
the face of a child and I said tell me
how you feeling now she said I'm feeling
all right I'm feeling like I'm not the
only one and so in that moment through a
letter I saw her get saved I know that
it's possible to do for every one of our
life every one of us in our lives to
help somebody to liberate somebody to
save somebody I know that the motto for
Howard is truth and service and I know
when you move through life living your
own truth and live through the paradigm
of service you too will be alright so I
beseech you to go forth and serve sir
first yourself honor your calling do
what you're supposed to do out of your
Creator your family your ancestors and
when you walk this path to privilege
don't forget the less privileged you
leave behind
dr. Oakland
you